All that stuff is legitimate.
It's a problem.
Something that should be looked at.
It's just a shame that the judging is so poor and it's been this way for so
long.
Well to the boxing,
I mean you have a,
then,
I'm not saying this in a derogatory way,
in some ways it's a good way,
but you have a dictator running,
you know,
you have safe and no,
but,
but it's okay to have a dictated sometimes because at least you have rules that
are,
he had to,
you have structure and uh,
you know,
as long as they're not,
taking people out and killing them.
I know what you're saying.
And so boxing has boxing.
He has no real
accountability,
no structure across the board.
No,
you don't real,
you know,
lateral structure and conformity,
not done unilateral because you have different states that have different
commissions and you know,
there's supposed to be tied together,
but they all act differently.
And there's no natural commission.
There's no body,
there's no dictated.
There's no czar.
There's no it,
there's no NBA commissioner,
there's no NFL commissioner,
there's no MLB commissioner that overlooks and polices the whole sport.
And
there's those separation of
church and state,
so to speak,
where the people making the money in the sport are separated,
truly separated from the people supposedly administrating this.
But there's no separation.
They,
I mean,
promoters actually that are making the money and have obviously a horse that
running in the game,
so to speak that night,
uh,
that they want that fighter to when they pay the judges.
And there's no,
there's no,
again,
there's no buffer.
There's no separation where you can have promoters and managers that can
actually go to the commission and say,
we don't want these judges to judge.
They can't say,
put this judge and,
but they can knock two inches out and in commissions.
We'll listen to them.
Uh,
the alphabet organizations,
they're corrupt.
Um,
they are,
I mean,
it's not teddy atlas saying it.
It's everybody saying that there's very few people that are going to say they're
not corrupt,
corrupt.
I mean,
if you're going to be honest about it and you're not,
and you don't have an agenda where you're afraid to say it because you have an
agenda,
which is a lot of people doing my business,
they have an agenda.
So they're not going to say dude,
because they're part of it.
If then are part of it.
Uh,
they're,
they're friendly with people that are part of it and,
uh,
they want to have access,
they want to have relationships.
So they say away from it and,
and they understand how the call should work so they understand,
uh,
you know,
is it,
is it a smoky room with cigars?
Like the old days were Frankie Carbo was one of the things and you put an
envelope,
no,
it's not diet,
but you might be paying $30,000 for an ad and,
and,
and uh,
at a convention for the WBA or the WBC or the w IBM for Wbl,
whatever the heck they are.
And you might be paying 30,000 an ad.
What,
what you,
you know,
why you paid the 30,000 for that?
I don't think that you just like to see,
um,
your name and add in a,
in a brochure.
There's,
there was a purpose behind paying that had.
And um,
so there's no,
again,
you have the administrators have to sport the commissions and then you have to
alphabet organizations that get paid a sanction and fee fund the champion.
So they want that champion to win.
And so they get to sanction fee.
And especially if he's a popular champion.
So they,
so now you have
no body saying,
well,
the manager can't talk to the sanction organization for modern account.
Of course they can talk to them and say,
I want my guys rated high.
Of course they have access.
So they have access to talking to somebody,
influencing somebody to move their guy up in the ratings,
these honest ratings.
And they have access to telling an organization.
While I,
you know,
I'd like to push a mandatory,
I like to push my guy to get the mandatory,
which means of course,
that he's going to fight them within a certain period of time.
He's got to fight to champion,
which I was missing.
You never may.
Yeah,
that's absolutely missing.
So you have all that stuff going on
and we're where,
where is the,
where's the,
where's the oversight?
Yeah.
Where's the of I,
where's the police in?
Where's the,
where's the line where,
because again,
people making money,
people running the sport,
people administrating this sport.
It's not supposed to blur a is supposed to be a separation.
Now if you know where to go in Europe,
America,
United States too,
but all through Europe where there's a lot of big fights too was just a big
fight with Joshua.
Uh,
in London they drew 90,000 people,
which is good for the sport and it's,
it's,
it's incredible.
Um,
but if you know where restaurant to go to tonight before big fight,
you were walking around.
So,
and I've been there,
you will walk in the restaurant.
I'm not going to say something.
And if I can't stand behind it,
and you will see at the restaurant and so big table kind of like,
you know,
not the last supper,
but it's,
it's a big table and you will see all the officials at that table that are going
to work to fight the next night.
And you will see the organizational heads,
the heads of that sanctioning body.
And,
and the guys that are in charge,
the presidents,
vice presidents,
um,
supervisors are judges,
referees.
And guess who the host of the dinners,
the promoter.
Somehow with that,
I mean there's something greatly wrong with that,
right?
So the host of the dead end,
it's a big bill obviously.
I mean it's a lot of people.
It's a good restaurant.
The eating all the best of drinking the best wines and everything else.
So it's a big bill and it's been picked up by the promoter who wants a specific
fight to win that night.
And he's got all,
he's got access to all the judges or the officials or the organizational heads
now.
So I would say to the people that are listening out there that,
just to make the analogy that really I think would hit home the New York Yankees
there obviously your universally known,
uh,
name and,
and Brant and the sort of organization maybe the biggest of all time.
So how about in New York?
You go to the best restaurant and the night before a world series game,
you walked into the restaurant and you saw all the umpiring crew,
all the officials that are in charge of the umpiring for the world series game,
sitting at a dinner hosted by the Steinbrenner's problem,
problem,
giant problem.
And it can't happen because there's a commission would never let that happen
because the integrity,
the credibility of Dysport would be down the tubes in one moment.
Right before you could finish your shrimp cocktail.
And,
but so it can't happen.
It happens on checked.
But it happens all the time in boxing.
And just to look of impropriety is wrong.
It should be wrong,
it should be worn.
The baseball,
it should be wrong and football should be wrong and MB,
but it should be even more wrong in a sport where you risked so much.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
Yeah,
it's a very,
very good point.
And I don't know how you would ever fix that.
I mean,
how would you have some universal oversight of the entire sport and how would
you get everybody from the Wbo Wba,
WBC.
They wouldn't.
No,
no.
They don't care enough because the president of the United States started Karen
when there was a problem with baseball.
He got,
he got involved.
That was about steroids though,
right?
Yeah,
but it was a problem.
It wasn't that a horseshit problem.
I mean,
it was a real problem,
but it was more of a problem of they wanted to clean up the image because it's
America's sport and they had these people,
they're worried about where the fence,
we're going to leave the game a little bit.
So it was a problem.
It was a problem that was impacting them.
It was impacting.
Listen,
it was impacting the perception of the game,
which impacted the,
the gates,
right.
What they're going to make.
And ultimately the fan base,
which of course impacts them financially.
Uh,
it impacts the country because of less people care about this sport.
Um,
you're gonna see it less and if you care about it,
you're going to be one of the people that are left out.
So it was a problem and they can't,
I don't,
I'm going to be careful saying this,
but not that careful,
but because you have to say it,
I don't think that they care as much about the people in boxing.
I don't think they do in there.
I just,
it's,
it's more of a dangerous,
dirty sport in their eyes.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the people that come into it and everything else,
how am I going to get into all the other stuff that you could get into that,
you know,
was so popular to get into in some ways nowadays?
You mean like racism?
Yeah.
I'm not going to get into that because
I don't want to,
and I don't have,
you know,
definitive things to show for that.
I just know how I will,
the precise,
it's not,
it's not cherished the way baseball's cherish when there's a big fight like
Canelo and triple g,
people get excited and a lot of people will buy it,
but it's not necessarily thought of as something that represents America.
And in particularly in canal triple g,
you're talking about two people that aren't American to begin with.
Yes.